merci d'être avec nous Valérie Létard et
nous accompagner pendant cette première
demi-heure sénatrice centriste du Nord
vice-présidente du Sénat et vous portez
une proposition de loi pour une aide
universelle pour les victimes de
violences conjugales on va bien sûr
longuement parler dans quelques instants
mais d'abord l'actualité c'est
évidemment la réforme des retraites
cinquième journée de mobilisation
aujourd'hui est-ce que cette réforme
peut être faite contre la rue et
l'opinion publique
je pense que on ne peut pas
être insensible et
ignoré ce que les Français nous
expriment en allant dans la rue on le
faisant respectueusement et je pense que
ce qu'on peut remarquer c'est que
aujourd'hui en fait ce qui s'exprime et
bien c'est tout simplement une
population des salariés des Français qui
s'inquiètent effectivement peut-être
aussi parce qu'ils ne comprennent plus
très bien ce qu'il en est de cette
réforme des retraites dont on mesure de
moins en moins bien les contours parce
que au fur et à mesure que des
ajustements sont proposés par le
gouvernement ou que les débats
s'organisent on a l'impression de
comprendre de moins en moins ce qui va
atterrir même nous parlementaire
nous devons regarder effectivement à
deux fois avant de comprendre ce qui va
nous être mis au débat alors d'abord
problème de pédagogie un problème de
méthode de la part du gouvernement ben
moi je j'avoue que
pour moi on est dans un pays où les
corps intermédiaires ont toujours eu
leur importance ou le Parlement on fait
partie les collectivités des territoires
le paritarisme et là on parle des
salariés on parle de quelque chose qui
est au cœur de leur mission et de leur
fonction il me semble que peut-être
la façon dont sa cela se construit
aurait peut-être dû être posée
différemment avoir un travail beaucoup
plus en amont essayez d'avoir un cadre
des lignes rouges un peu plus partagées
avec les partenaires sociaux des
ambitions des objectifs on sait qu'il
faut réformer ses retraites est-ce que
le gouvernement n'est pas arrivé avec
quelque chose de trop ficelé présenté
alors on parle de concertation à ce que
c'est une concertation une information
est-ce qu'on a vraiment laissé un espace
pour défigures libres qu'il y a un cadre
des figures imposées c'est le rôle du
gouvernement d'abord comment construire
ce cadre est-ce qu'on a pris la
température en amont et ensuite comment
on discute et on a juste les choses en
prenant justement la température du
terrain de tous partenaires sociaux
patronat syndicat pour essayer de
s'approcher de ce qu'attendre les
Français et de le faire avec aussi de la
lisibilité de la clarté l'exemple de
1200 euros dont on ne sait plus pour qui
comment quand c'est aussi symptomatique
de ce que peut générer en tout cas
auprès de la population ce qui est en
train de se passer il faut que les
choses soient claires pour qu'elles
soient soutenue ce qu'on ne comprend pas
il est difficile d'y adhérer c'est un
peu ça le sujet si déjà cette méthode la
temporalité on arrive avec cette réforme
des retraites d'un seul coup d'un seul
après enfin voilà le l'Ukraine a généré
une perte de pouvoir d'achat une réalité
en termes d'inflation la crise de
l'énergie qui s'est accélérée
des choses qu'on attendait
la temporalité on sait qu'il faut faire
une réforme des retraites et si je peux
dire un dernier élément
mes collègues des affaires sociales me
disaient que dans les auditions par
exemple la CFDT explique que la réforme
des retraites de 3 c'est 30 milliards
d'économies la réforme de 2010 50
milliards d'économies et quand l'état
actuel de l'art de la réforme de 2023 on
atterrit en ce moment un peu moins de 10
milliards au travers des différentes
mesures qui sont proposées donc on est
en train d'inquiéter tout le monde le
sentiment que c'est pas juste parce que
c'est pas compris et pour un effort
budgétaire qui a ce stade apparaît
l'épaisseur du trait à côté des besoins
il faut réformer comment le fait-on
est-ce la bonne méthode la bonne
temporalité je n'ai pas d'avis tranché
aujourd'hui le débat n'a pas eu lieu au
Sénat mais vous êtes réticente à voter
cette réforme parce que ça arrive dans
pas longtemps aujourd'hui j'aimerais
bien comprendre l'intérêt contre en plus
une population qui ne comprend plus où
on l'emmène qui sent qui a besoin d'une
réforme voilà comment avance-t-on
comment aujourd'hui on redresse le cap
est-ce que c'est possible moi je n'ai
pas d'avis arrêté aujourd'hui mais voilà
je m'inquiète parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de points qui aujourd'hui font que que
ce soit le par charisme que ce soit la
population que ce soit même nous
parlementaires on a envie d'être acteur
on n'a pas envie de ne pas jouer notre
rôle mais encore faut-il que on est des
espaces de respiration si on veut
modifier des choses l'article 47
s'applique donc on ne peut pas le faire
sans l'accord du gouvernement vous
voulez changer des mesures budgétaires
vous êtes impacté vous n'avez pas le
droit de prendre des décisions et des
mesures budgétaires si elles ne sont pas
acceptées par le gouvernement et enfin
voilà on voit bien qu'on est dans
quelque chose vous ne savez pas quelle
sera votre vote à titre personnel moi
j'attends de voir effectivement ce que
les débats vont donner c'est partager il
y a des c'est une position qui est
partagée dans votre groupe
il y a des gens qui qui sont dans une
logique de vote du du texte évidemment
on en débat on en discute dans notre
groupe il y en a qui s'interroge comme
je m'interroge mais parce que voilà
d'abord quel texte va sortir de
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui et
sans vouloir m'échapper d'une décision
moi je suis triste de voir que un sujet
sur lequel on doit avancer ben on l'a
embarqué d'une façon dont on se demande
si c'est pas là aujourd'hui tout de
suite maintenant parce que le Président
de la République veut donner des gages
peut-être à l'Europe sur une bonne
gestion sur un mais qu'est-ce que vous
attendez pour voter ce texte qu'est-ce
qui doit y avoir pour que vous votiez ce
texte mais d'abord que on est une une
vision claire effectivement pour chaque
citoyen savoir effectivement ce que l'on
vote à qui ça s'adresse aujourd'hui il
faut recadrer un petit peu tout ça il y
a des sujets que vous connaissez très
bien c'est la retraite des femmes les
carrières longues la pénibilité les
familles enfin il y a plein de choses à
prendre en compte c'est vrai bon là
maintenant c'est sorti du débat mais la
question de l'emploi des seniors qui dit
travailler plus longtemps que font les
seniors s'il y a pas d'emploi qui
s'offrent à eux comment tout ça c'est
pas vraiment sorti du débat parce
qu'Olivier du seuble dit qu'il compte
sur le Sénat pour remettre cette index
seniors à le remettre vous et ben moi je
pense que si on veut allonger les
carrières professionnelles il faut quand
même que des seniors on puisse
l'accompagner qui est peut-être des
mesures d'encourageant d'accompagnement
d'incitation pour que effectivement
c'est c'est possible qu'il soit offertes
aux seniors soient réelles et que les
entreprises et ben elles aient peut-être
des des accompagnement mais aussi des
obligations quand je dis des obligations
bien falloir des incitations pour que
les entreprises aillent dans cette
direction mais aujourd'hui que va-t-il
arriver ici quels seront les marges
manœuvre pourquoi faire et avec quel
intérêt quel bénéfice à cette réforme on
passe à l'actualité du jour au Sénat et
elle vous concerne Valérie Létard
puisque cet après-midi le Sénat va
examiner en deuxième lecture la
proposition de loi dont vous êtes
l'auteur qui vise à accorder une note
d'urgence aux victimes de violences
conjugales ont fait le point avec Audrey
[Musique]
bonjour et Audrey la proposition de loi
de Valérie létharisons à mettre à l'abri
une personne victime d'un conjoint
violent revient donc au Sénat après
avoir été adopté à l'unanimité à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'est-ce qui va
se passer et bien la navette suit son
cours l'assemblée vous l'avez dit à
adopter la proposition de loi à
l'unanimité je pense que c'est important
de le souligner en y apportant quelques
modifications mais comme il faut que les
deux textes soient identiques alors on
le réexamine au Sénat qu'est-ce qui a
changé à l'Assemblée d'abord je rappelle
que vous aviez proposé une aide
financière d'urgence destinée aux
victimes de violences conjugales femmes
et hommes pourquoi parce que les
victimes sont souvent sous l'emprise
financière de leur conjoint violent et
c'est un frein au départ vous aviez
prévu que cette aide prenne la forme
d'un prêt sans intérêt avec des
modalités de remboursement une aide
universelle le gouvernement a ajouté la
possibilité que ce soit un don écoutez
les explications d'Isabelle Rome la
ministre en charge de l'égalité femme
homme elle a été au micro d'Aurélien
Romano
j'ai souhaité que ce soit un don pour
permettre aux victimes de partir encore
plus vite et sans préoccupation de
remboursement je pense que c'est très
important parce que ça pourra vraiment
permettre de sauver des vies
est-ce que ça change des choses et bien
la ministre madame Rome a souhaité
préciser en tout cas dans l'écriture qui
s'est faite à l'Assemblée la nature de
l'aide c'est vrai que au Sénat nous
avons parce que nous tenions et je
tenais particulièrement après en avoir
travaillé le contenu avec les
professionnels de terrain et en mesurant
effectivement la complexité du sujet ce
qu'on voulait c'est l'universalité on
peut avoir 3000 euros de salaire par
mois et être privé de son compte
bancaire de sa carte de crédit parce
qu'on est sous l'emprise psychologique
et financière d'un conjoint qui peut
être violent menaçant et être en
difficulté et ne pas pouvoir s'engager
dans un projet de départ parce que
démuni de tout quelquefois de papier
encore une fois on peut être une jeune
de moins de 25 ans ne pas avoir droit au
RSA d'avoir aucune ressource et avoir
besoin de sentir que si on doit quitter
le domicile si on se retrouve au
commissariat parce qu'on a subi des
violences ou à l'hôpital comment je fais
pour partir sans savoir si je pourrais
bénéficier d'une aide en attendant qu'on
me donne des droits qu'on rétablisse mes
droits si j'en ai car si j'ai moins de
25 ans je n'ai pas droit à RSA si je
n'ai pas d'enfant donc l'idée c'était de
dire comme malheureusement beaucoup de
femmes avec ou sans enfant son petit à
petit mis sous empris sous dépendance
non seulement psychologique mais
financière administrative quelquefois il
fallait imaginer quelque chose qui sous
72 heures maximum puissent être
débloqués pour donner une sécurité à une
personne victime de violence femme ou
homme car il y a aussi des hommes qui
peuvent être victimes de violence même
s'ils sont beaucoup moins nombreux ils
existent il y a aussi il faut dire
homosexuel qui peuvent à l'intérieur du
couple homosexuel subir ces violences
pourquoi cette aide je le dis dans mon
temps équivalent RSA c'est ce qu'on
souhaite ça se définira par décret c'est
de la ministre qu'en aura besoin ce prêt
puisque c'est un prêt que nous avions
imaginé mais après dont on avait défini
que il puisse être transformé en aide
non remboursable
partiellement remboursable ou totalement
remboursable en fonction de la situation
de la personne je suis au rsa demain une
fois que ma situation est rétablie je ne
saurais pas remboursé on fait une remise
totale de ce prêt c'était l'esprit de la
proposition initiale j'ai un salaire je
vais avoir 3000 euros par mois je
récupère au bout d'un mois mon salaire
je peux le rembourser et c'est même pas
à moi qui vais le rembourser puisque
dans la proposition de loi initiale que
nous avons imaginé on va chercher
l'auteur des violences pour rembourser
le prêt quand c'est un prêt mais donc
vous le voyez bien l'idée initiale
c'était dire ça peut être un don mais
nous on le disait pas comme ça on dit
c'est un prêt mais en fonction de la
situation de ressources se prêt il ne
fait pas l'objet d'un remboursement il
est donc il fait l'objet d'une année non
remboursable où il est partiellement ou
totalement remboursable selon ma
situation de ressources pourquoi on a
fait ça on a fait ça pour que quel que
soit ma situation que je sois jeune moi
jeune personne âgée que j'ai des moyens
ou j'en ai pas je peux me retrouver dans
cette situation dépendante pendant un
mois deux mois trois mois alors le temps
de retourner mes droits madame la
ministre dit dont mais c'est dont en
fait elle dit la même chose j'ai pas de
ressources on transforme cette aide
universelle en aide non rembourse c'est
pas un don pour tout le monde bien sûr
que non si j'ai un salaire évidemment ou
l'auteur des violences rembourse à ma
place ou si il s'avère que l'auteur est
un solvable on regarde la situation il
peut y avoir une remise partielle ou
totale de ce prêt de cette aide
universelle ce qui est important de se
dire c'est aujourd'hui elle est vraiment
elle n'exclut personne c'est ce que nous
voulions c'est ce qui apparaissait sur
le terrain si on ne touche que des gens
ou des dames ou des monsieur qui ont
droit au RSA alors on fait fausse route
donc elle est adaptée c'est une forme de
prêt mais d'aide aussi universelle qui
fait que toute personne en fonction de
cette situation pourrait bénéficier du
net financière suffisante pour pouvoir
porter aller vers le rebond quitter le
domicile ou s'éloigner de l'auteur de
violence c'est peut-être aussi l'auteur
des violences qui peut quitter le
domicile mais en tout cas il faut un
minimum de ressources pour pouvoir
préparer ce projet on va parler du
remboursement mais aimer d'abord Audrey
les modalités on vous en avez un petit
peu parlé Valérie l'État les modalités
et le montant de cette aide alors il y a
des conditions il faut qu'il y ait eu
une plainte ou une ordonnance de
protection le montant on ne le connaît
pas encore en fait il sera fixé par des
crêpes vous voudriez l'équivalent du RSA
en trois mensualités versées par la CAF
l'aide serait débloquée dans les trois
jours sauf et c'est une modification de
l'Assemblée si la victime n'est pas
allocataire social dans ce cas là ce
sera dans un délai qui peut s'étendre
jusqu'à 5 jours mais je voulais aussi
revenir sur une modification que vous
voulez le gouvernement et que
l'assemblée a rejeté la majorité voulait
que les personnes qui reçoivent cet aide
soit en situation régulière sur le
territoire français ça a été rejeté à
l'Assemblée vous comprenez mais écoutez
dans le texte initial nous ne les
rejetons pas quand vous allez
questionner les associations surtout
dans les territoires plus denses plus
métropolitain il s'avère qu'une partie
significative des femmes victimes de
violence malheureusement ne sont pas en
situation régulière est-ce qu'il faut
exclure et laisser une femme
risquée de mourir sous les coups de son
conjoint sous prétexte qu'elle n'a pas
régularisé sa situation je ne suis pas
sûr que ce soit bien raisonnable je ne
suis favorable à ce que nous ayons une
politique de l'immigration myométrisée
qu'on l'a choisi ce qu'on l'a subisse
pas mais à partir du moment où une femme
est sur le territoire national très
souvent n'a pas
se retrouve dans une situation où parce
qu'elle n'a pas régularisé effectivement
sa situation elle soit enfin voilà tenue
de rester à son domicile à une piste pas
bénéficier de l'aide je ne suis pas sûr
en tout cas que cette décision cette
proposition qui était faite par le
gouvernement on peut en comprendre le
sens mais en l'occurrence c'est plutôt
en amont qu'il faut agir quand la femme
est là enfin je ne je ne vois pas enfin
c'est humainement je ne vois pas comment
on peut défendre ça et en tout cas moi
j'y suis favorable après peut-être que
le gouvernement souhaitera à mettre des
dispositions qui s'adaptent peut-être à
des personnes en situation irrégulière
mais il faut les prendre en compte d'une
manière ou d'une autre c'est un peu
l'esprit de cette loi une universalité
une femme victime de violence il faut
l'aider à s'éloigner des risques qui
peuvent aller jusqu'au décès vous savez
que depuis le covid il y a eu une
explosion il y a une forte augmentation
des violences conjugales des violences
intrafamiliales car les enfants sont
malheureusement touchés aussi et il est
plus urgent de combler ce trou dans la
raquette qui existe cette difficulté
financière qui malheureusement trop
souvent au dire des encore une fois des
acteurs de terrain que ce soit dans les
commissariats les services sociaux les
associations nous le disent un des
freins au départ c'est quand même cette
phase qui existe entre l'urgence
immédiate et le moment où on peut
rétablir des droits une situation un
emploi une formation et que je sois
retraité je peux être victime de
violence que je sois moins de 25 ans ou
entre 25 et 65 ans il y a pas de
différence il faut pouvoir aider ces
femmes on le fait de façon raisonnable
responsable encadrée si on veut faire de
la grande cause du quinquennat les
violences conjugales alors il faut s'en
donner les moyens ça veut dire que le
texte tel qu'il est sorti de l'Assemblée
nationale vous convient que du coup il y
aura un vote identique cet après-midi
vous espérez encore un vote à
l'unanimité j'espère sincèrement un vote
à l'unanimité conforme même si j'aurais
proposer quelques petites améliorations
mais objectivement repartir dans une
navette et dans une discussion alors que
ce texte il est attendu par les
professionnels sur le terrain il a été
construit avec c'est vraiment un
dispositif il vient compléter l'arsenal
des outils des acteurs qui sont
mobilisés 24 heures sur 24 vous le savez
les associations sont mobilisées les
services sociaux même police gendarmerie
il y a des tas de dispositifs qui sont
mis en place les gens travaillent
ensemble ils leur manque il y a des
trous dans la raquette celui-là il était
quand même assez conséquent grande cause
du quinquennat on parle du pack nouveau
départ la première ministrement faire
une priorité le 8 mars c'est bientôt
mais là c'est même un cadeau qu'on fait
au gouvernement de donner la
l'opportunité au travers d'une
initiative parlementaire du Sénat je
remercie aussi nos collègues de
l'Assemblée nationale qui quand on voit
les débats aujourd'hui ont su sur un
sujet de cette importance d'intérêt
général trouver les moyens d'être
unanime et d'apporter leur contribution
concrètement vous espérez une mise en
oeuvre pour quand et bien
j'envisage une mise en oeuvre bien en
tout cas promulgation rapide si nous
faisons un vote conforme et c'est l'idée
c'est on va tout de suite on fait pas
une navette et derrière le gouvernement
a dit maximum 9 mois à accepter une
disposition qui raccourcisse le délai
d'application à 9 mois pourquoi neuf
mois on pourrait dire plus vite mais il
faut que nos caisses d'allocations
familiales créent les logiciels les
outils qui vont permettre de débloquer
les moyens après vous l'avez dit nous on
a défendu l'idée d'un équivalent du RSA
familiarisé c'est à dire qu'on complète
par le nombre d'enfants à charge quand
il y a des enfants qui partent avec avec
la personne victime et il faut vraiment
que ce soit sale sujet il faut vraiment
que ce soit ça si on saucissonne les
aides à ce moment-là on n'est plus au
rendez-vous et le montant va le
connaître quand et bien c'est le décret
et donc là on compte beaucoup sur le
gouvernement parce que les modalités
d'attribution le décret va définir ces
modalités ce montant j'espère que nous
serons associés j'ai cru comprendre que
je serai associé à l'élaboration de ce
décret je serai attentive à ce que ça
soit à la hauteur des attentes et des
engagements merci Audrey à tout à
l'heure dans le club on parle de la
réforme des retraites évidemment on va
voir l'actualité dans votre département
du Nord Valérie d'État on valide où on
retrouve Pierre Giraud Montenot
rédacteur en chef de Wéo qui a deux
questions à vous poser et la première
concerne le sujet dont on vient de
parler les violences conjugales
bonjour madame la sénatrice la région
des Hauts de France enregistre un nombre
de violences conjugales supérieur à la
moyenne nationale de près trois points
15 féminicides ont lieu en 2021 dans les
hauts de France les chiffres stagnent on
ne progresse pas dans ce domaine là
alors ma question est la suivante à quoi
se heurte les politiques publiques pour
faire baisser ces tendances et quelles
sont les leviers sur lesquels vous
pouvez agir
bonjour monsieur Montenot et bien très
concrètement celui dont je viens de
parler est essentiel et il est d'autant
plus essentiel que vous le savez dans
notre région et dans notre département
la réalité socio-économique la précarité
des familles fait que bien peut-être il
y a encore une importance plus
significative de cette emprise
financière dont on parlait vous avez
aussi peut-être cette période covid on
en a parlé elle a fortement accentué le
pourcentage de violence chez nous ça a
augmenté de plus de 10% je ne sais pas
si c'est même pas justement 13% donc
supérieur effectivement à l'augmentation
nationale mais la précarité aussi
peut-être du logement des familles la
cohabitation quelquefois de plusieurs
générations
des conditions effectivement si
peut-être de précarité de ces logements
on fait que on a une situation peut-être
plus lourde c'est bien pour ça euh
monsieur Montenot je me suis emparée de
ce sujet c'est que quand vient d'une
expérimentation à Valentine d'ailleurs
en fait je suis élu départementale et à
ce titre je participe à des commissions
d'arrondissement dans lesquelles on
réunit tout le monde tous les acteurs
qui s'occupent de ces violences
intrafamilales du procureur les
commissaires la gendarmerie les services
sociaux les associations les bailleurs
et on voit bien on arrive vite à
comprendre ce qui manque quels sont les
trous dans la raquette le besoin de
logement dédié le besoin d'adapter des
solutions en matière d'éviction de
l'auteur des violences d'accompagnement
psychologique des femmes victimes de
prévention tout ça monsieur Montenot
évidemment et bien il faut le compléter
l'améliorer le département effectivement
s'engage dans ces dynamiques l'ensemble
des acteurs puisque là tout le monde
joue le jeu mais c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui il va falloir aussi
peut-être aller plus loin dans la
coordination dans l'accompagnement dans
le suivi des personnes victimes qui a un
référent un fil rouge c'est peut-être
aussi chaque nouveau départ et pourtant
les chiffres sont toujours terribles il
y a eu 122 féminicides l'année dernière
enfin en 2021 il y a près de 300000
victimes annuelles de violences
conjugales selon les chiffres du
ministère de l'intérieur c'est aussi un
échec du Grenelle des violences
conjugales qu'on en soit encore là mais
je pense que il faut prendre
c'est comme tout on peut faire des on y
a eu un gros travail de sensibilisation
qui a permis de libérer la parole qui a
permis de prendre conscience dans notre
société de
l'énormité du sujet il y a pas une
catégorie qui est épargnée par ces
réalités de violences conjugales on le
voit tous les jours mais il y a en plus
un phénomène de précarité qui vient
s'additionner à ça et qui aggrave les
situations mais ce qui est certain c'est
que si on ne met pas les moyens on a
fait le travail de communication de
sensibilisation d'information
donnons-nous les moyens en voilà très
concret c'est le premier moyen concret
de ce quinquennat qu'on pourrait voir
arriver très enfin voilà une dame en
situation de fragilité peut aller
chercher cette aide cet énorme c'est une
avancée mais il faut que le gouvernement
aille plus loin soutiennent les
associations il y a beaucoup d'acteurs
aussi qui ont besoin d'être aidés au
quotidien pour faire un bon travail
auprès de ces personnes victimes on
retourne dans le Nord voir Pierre Jérôme
montre-nous qui a une deuxième question
à vous poser sur un tout autre sujet on
l'écoute
madame la sénatrice le Nord est plus
particulièrement le Valenciennois se
prépare à la révolution de l'industrie
automobile
trois installations d'usine géantes de
batterie sont annoncées une quatrième
étalitude notamment près de chez vous
que comptez-vous faire pour que cette
quatrième gigafactory comment les
appelle arrive sur votre territoire
mais vous le savez monsieur Montenot
nous sommes dans une région qui a
toujours porté fortement l'ambition
industrielle d'abord vous le savez les
hauts de France et particulièrement les
départements du Nord et du Pas-de-Calais
sont des départements de culture
industrielle que ce soit dans la
métropole où on était plutôt sur le
textile que ce soit dans le sud du
département d'où je viens dans le
Valenciennois où il y avait une
tradition de débat de l'acide ururgie il
y avait aussi bien sûr l'industrie
minière mais bref c'est la culture de
notre région aujourd'hui
Xavier Bertrand vous le savez la région
des Hauts-de-France de son côté est très
mobilisé sur ces sujets a toujours été
très proactifs à accompagner très
concrètement financièrement il y a
beaucoup oeuvré pour faire venir les
industriels il faut travailler la
filière monsieur Montenot c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui
l'électromobilité notre indépendance la
mutation en fait de l'automobile vers le
véhicule propre c'est nécessite de
construire de la recherche l'innovation
la formation les équipements qui doivent
être présents il faut construire tous
l'écosystème qui va permettre
aujourd'hui d'être comme le dit le
disent beaucoup la vallée de
l'électromobilité on s'en donne les
conditions le gouvernement est au
rendez-vous aussi sur ce sujet mais
vraiment la région s'est mis en
situation d'être au rendez-vous de
l'accompagnement avec des hommes et des
femmes pré-embarquer tout ça Valérie
Leta on veut remercier d'abord pierre
Jérôme monte non quel rédacteur en chef
de eau la télévision locale de chez vous
du Nord merci beaucoup pierre Jérôme un
dernier mot pour parler du zan zéro
artificielisation net puisqu'on a parlé
rien industrialisation c'est une
inquiétude pour les maires pour les élus
locaux cette question d'usane vous
présenter une proposition de loi à ce
sujet elle sera examinée le 14 mars quel
est l'objectif et bien le 14 mars le
souhait du Sénat et de façon
transpartisane puisque la proposition de
loi que nous porterons avec
Jean-Baptiste blanc et bien c'est une
proposition de loi qui est qu'au signée
par le groupe communiste le groupe
socialiste les républicains les
centrices bref vous le voyez c'est une
proposition qui a fait l'objet d'un
travail trans partisan qui vise à
assouplir un texte de loi émanant de la
loi climat et qui vise à la sobriété
foncière moins consommer d'espace mais
ce qui a été défini c'est moins 50% de
consommation foncière à horizon 203230
c'est demain mais très concrètement ça
veut dire que l'on va devoir en fait
réduire les surfaces constructives on va
avoir ce qu'on appelle des injonctions
contradictoires on vient de parler de
gigafactory les giga Factory elles sont
très consommatrices d'espace derrière il
va falloir construire des logements pour
les salariés il va falloir faire des
zones pour les équipementsiers tout ça
va venir manger de l'enveloppe pour les
collectivités locales il va y avoir le
sénor il va y avoir le parking du brexit
comment tout ça va venir être contenu
dans une enveloppe divisée par deux
quand on a besoin de plus c'est tout
l'enjeu comment assouplir des règles du
jeu tout en étant sobre foncièrement bah
c'est voilà trouver ces souplesse
aujourd'hui l'État et le gouvernement
nous proposait très rigide qui font peur
aux élus locaux trouvons les voies et
moyens d'atteindre les objectifs en
prenant compte la vraie vie et ce sera
le 14 mars au Sénat j'espère que vous
viendrez nous en parler à ce moment-là
de ces âmes qui inquiète beaucoup les
élus locaux merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous dans 20 minutes dans le club
des territoires on parle de la réforme
des retraites nouvelles journées de
mobilisation et débats suivre entre le
porte-parole du PC Yann brossa il
apporte-parole de renaissance prescat
théveno d'abord on accueille notre
prochaine invité c'est Marine Tondelier
qui nous rejoint